Thanos was fighting Dr Doom and Thor and
it's amazing check this out so what this
does here is this picks up based on a
couple different things that we've
covered so far as always you'll find a
link to the Thor playlist down below the
like button here on the video but to
kind of cover this a little bit Thor was
visited by his sister laosa from the
future and she showed up because she was
sent by Thor's future self to give his
younger self a message lhasa in terms of
being Thor's sister is kind of but not
directly what ended up happening is that
Thor's adopted mother Freya basically
ended up procreating with a Demon server
and that's where laosa comes from but
Freya is not really the biological
mother of Thor's is like stepmom so I
don't know exactly how you want to
square that Circle but what she
basically told him is go check on you're
dead and it was just a really ambiguous
message and then she jumped into a
timestorm and went back to the future
and that was effectively it now once
this happened this is where we started
picking up on this kind of whodunit
mystery in the Thor comics where Thor
went to Valhalla and the whole place was
empty all the souls of Valhalla were
gone and we didn't know who took them we
had no idea where they went to now one
of the things that happens is that
walthor's here he's met by Valkyrie now
one of the things you remember here is
that when it comes to Valkyrie that's
basically Jane Foster yes she was Thor
in Marvel Comics for a period of time
anybody who ever reads comics will tell
you things always go back to the status
quo eventually which is why I just kind
of spare yourself to trouble don't worry
about getting upset whenever Marvel
changes things enjoy the ride take the
story for what it's worth it'll all go
back to normal in the end and so once
Jane Foster stopped being Thor she
basically became a valkyrie meaning she
basically guides the bodies of The
Honorable dead to Valhalla if they die
in honorable combat and to a degree
she's kind of charged with keeping
Valhalla safe as a kind of personal
guard so she takes it as like a personal
failure when all these souls in Valhalla
had effectively gone missing and that
leads her to joined Thor on the hunt
because the next place he goes to based
on this statement from lhasa is of
course the most logical location to the
realm of hell where hella rules
everything but when he gets there the
entire place is empty too there's nobody
there well there there are people there
right you have like the Val Raven who
are there but they're kind of like
feeding on those few Souls Who Remain
but for the most part the places largely
empty here now the valraven are not
overly important this is just kind of
Marvel kind of establishing to us and
reminding us that the realm of hell is a
much bigger place and that's an
important distinction to understand here
that back in the day in Marvel Comics
hell was just the general afterlife for
anybody who died that changed when
Marvel introduced mistress death and
gave us like a true afterlife and other
gods and goddesses were introduced that
had dealings with Mortal men and women
but the valravian themselves just kind
of sit on the outskirts of the realm of
hell and those individuals who were
unfortunate enough to stumble across
their path are basically consumed but
because the Val Raven exists to consume
The Souls of the Dead havla largely just
kind of keeps them chained up out there
because if they were given free reign
they would just gobble up everything in
existence right and not all the souls
that are here are bad people it's just
they've been here for a really long time
so the thing about this is that as Thor
and as Jane Foster make their way
through they initially confront the
valraven there's not a whole lot doing
here there's kind of a bit of a fight
but they keep talking about how he is
here right it is here that it is
attacking and destroying everything and
we end up finding out that it's
basically nidhog right now within Marvel
Comics this is just another being that
exists in the realm of hell that
consumes Souls but it's basically a
dragon right and it's astronomically
powerful what's so funny about this is
that it's supposed to have been
destroyed eons ago but somehow or
another it's been resurrected now in
terms of How It's depicted within the
Thor Comics it's something that does not
have a soul somehow has a soul now right
this thing doesn't have a true heart but
there's a heart inside it beating all
this is really doing is just saying this
thing's been brought back using a
combination of necromancy and technology
and that's it right this is a kind of
like a hollow shell being controlled
more by Machine than anything else but
when Thor gives the upper hand on this
It ultimately Retreats and Thor simply
follows it to its location once that
happens we transition to the guy who's
basically behind all of this the
emptying of Valhalla the emptying of
hell and as you would probably expect it
turns out to be Doctor Doom because why
not right because why not Doctor Doom is
always vying for power and in this
instance what he's doing is he's
breaking Souls which is amazing and in
fact he's captured hella now we'll find
out how he did that here in a little
while but he basically kind of torments
her to a degree and in fact what he's
trying to do is invoke a spell and we'll
talk about that spell as we get further
into this video but he's trying to
invoke a spell for the purpose of
basically attaining absolute power now
one of the things to know here right
this is an important distinction to
understand if you're new to Marvel
Comics you may find yourself asking the
question how can someone like Dr Doom go
toe-to-toe against a goddess like hella
isn't there some kind of a hierarchy yes
there is a hierarchy there but Dr Doom
is one of these characters that exists
out there that because his knowledge in
magic and sorcery is so Advanced it
basically elevates him up right once
your power achieves a certain level
there is no differentiation between like
gods and Cosmic entities and so on and
so forth right like it's really just
levels of power varying degrees of power
durability strength that separate these
things so the answer to your question is
yes there is a hierarchy here but the
reality is the hierarchy that separates
mortal man from like Asgardian gods and
Cosmic entities and different things
like that it's just varying levels of
power and degrees of invulnerability or
durability but given the nature of
someone like Dr Doom and the amount of
magical knowledge that he has he can
Elevate his capabilities he can make
himself more powerful and that really
pushes them Beyond simply just being a
dude in Marvel Comics who does some
magical stuff sometimes and like fights
a Fantastic Four occasionally it
elevates him to a much higher level it's
kind of a shortcut if you want to call
it that but the thing about this is that
hella goes so far as to say what you're
trying to do here Doom is a losing game
right breaking Souls it takes a vast
amount of energy to do that but of
course Dr Doom's motivation in response
to this is as basic as it ever is which
is Doctor Doom wants to conquer the
world because he believes that he can
make the world better than what it is
that's always his motivation it's
usually cloaked and blanketed in some
grand scheme like during doommore when
he invaded wakanda and installed all the
vibranium that's basically just him
trying to use vibranium to amplify his
own magical energy and take over the
world which he almost did he was like a
hair's breath away from being able to
pull it off right but even then as hella
refuses to answer the question of Doom
which is how do I cast this spell he
ultimately ends up bringing out the soul
of carnilla now carnella is like the
love interest of hella so it's basically
Doctor Doom taking the soul of her wife
and then saying like I will destroy the
soul of the woman you care about if you
do not tell me what it is that I want to
know now that's one of the big
differences between the Asgardian gods
and almost any other gods that exist in
Marvel Comics you take the goddess of
Bass from the Black Panther Mythos or
Zeus from Olympus that they are almost
very inhuman they're disconnected from
any real emotional entanglements it
doesn't mean to say that they don't get
angry or happy or anything like that but
you don't really see them having the
same Almost Human elements as you do
with people like hella or Odin or Bohr
or anybody like that and so because of
the fact that basically Dr Doom is
threatening to destroy her love interest
Hela starts spilling the beans now even
after telling him how to cast this spell
she still tells him it's a Fool's errand
right the Amber that you're using here
to basically break Souls apart to burn
these Souls that sure that comes from
the Galactus seed the thing that created
the universe itself but at the end of
the day it doesn't matter because you
need the actual Galactus seed itself now
if you guys recall the video that we did
we were talking about how Thanos created
a new infinity stone which is part of
this Thor line of comics that we talked
about how boar when he was actually
casting this spell right boar being the
grandfather of Thor that he was using
the physical Galactus seed itself it was
the only way he was able to pull that
spell off without a hitch but the
Galactus seed is not something easily
attained and as far as our wear in
Marvel Comics The Galactus seed is
within Bohr's vault which is not easily
attained and in fact it can't even be
accessed at the moment it's just kind of
locked away it used to be in the world
tree within Asgard itself but it was
ultimately removed the bigger point that
she's making here is that doctor Doom's
not going to be able to pull the spell
off it's never going to work no matter
how hard he tries no matter how many
souls he burns it's never going to
happen but the funny thing about this is
that Doctor Doom even references what
went on with boar with regards to him
casting the spell and he talks about how
boar had failed when he initially cast
it and the response of hella is what are
you talking about boar didn't fail when
he was trying to cast that spell and
created the black infinity stone boar
succeeded right now that's the cool
thing here is because in the comments
section of that video where we talked
about how Thanos had created that
infinity stone a lot of you guys called
The Stone right off the bat a lot of you
guys were like I know exactly what that
stone is and you were right
right for those of you guys who know
what I'm talking about a little bit of a
spoiler here you were 100 right I didn't
believe you I was like ah no no you know
you guys were right you guys called it
right hats off so of course Thor and
Valkyrie end up arriving here in
latviria and when they do a fight to a
degree unfolds between Thor and Doctor
Doom not immediately though because one
of the things to remember about Doom is
that this guy is what we in the color
book industry refer to as a dick because
what this dude does is he basically
takes all these different human soldiers
here in in Liberia itself and using his
own power effectively takes them over
and then forces them to turn their guns
on Thor and then following that when it
doesn't necessarily work he sends them
all running to jump off of a cliff but
the reason why he does this is because
Dr Doom knows Thor well enough to know
that Thor is a hero first right so what
he's gonna end up doing is he's
basically going to like try to save all
these people and it's going to allow Dr
Dr Doom the time he needs to try to
complete this spell it's a smart
maneuver I mean it is a very smart thing
to do but in the end it still doesn't
work that ultimately the spell never
comes out in doctor Doom's favor and the
only thing that he can possibly do here
is to retreat and so what ends up
happening is he jumps through a Time
Vortex because what this will do is
it'll send him back in time to when boar
was initially casting the spell The Hope
here of Doctor Doom is he could
basically take boar out right he could
kill Bohr and then in turn with the
entire landscape clear seize the stone
for himself and then recreate reality
the funny thing about this is Dr Doom
does not know Thanos is already there
because Thanos was also time displaced
so what you're seeing here is this
situation where these different
characters Thanos Doctor Doom Thor
they're all arriving in the distant past
when boar is casting the spell to create
this black infinity stone and they're
arriving there by whatever Manner and
whatever he means but all their goals
are the same now the reason for this is
still a little bit ambiguous Marvel has
not fully fleshed out the nature of the
black infinity stone the only thing we
know about it is that Thor had some
vision during Donnie Kate's initial run
when he became a Herald of Galactus that
Thanos was like standing there with the
Infinity Stones on mjolnir a black
infinity stone on one hand leading an
army of zombies that's all we knew right
that's the only thing we know about the
block infinity stone make sure you guys
check below the like button for the link
to that video but the thing about this
is that because Thor is of course trying
to ensure that Doctor Doom is not
successful Thor ends up jumping through
the time portal as well and when that
happens you end up with Thor Thanos and
Dr Doom all in the same location two of
these guys want to seize the black
infinity stone to recreate all of
creation and one guy wants to stop them
so we get the inevitable conflict that
we talked about at the beginning of this
video because hell is initially freed
right hell is freed by Thor and hell is
like no man I gotta go back to hell and
I got to get that place sorted out right
I got more important fish to fry you go
into the past and you deal with Dr Doom
and Thanos that'll be your thing now the
funny thing about this is that Boar's
already gone by this point in time and
so when Dr Doom arrives in the past he
ends up coming face to face with Thanos
now the thing about this is that these
guys have met multiple times they've
never had a one-on-one fight though well
they kind of had in secret Wars but that
doesn't really count I'm talking about
like the main Marvel Universe when it's
just Doctor Doom as his normal self and
Thanos as his normal self because in
secret Wars that was when Dr Dooms like
rip Thanos spine out and killed him on
the spot but he had the power of the
beyonders so that's cheating that's not
really fair but the thing about this is
that as the two of them are here right
Dr Doom kind of goads Thanos to a degree
now have no Illusions here right like
yes thanos's time displaced yes Thanos
wants to destroy or sees this black
infinity stone for himself but he also
understands the power that Doctor Doom
possesses and that's something that is
very easily overlooked here right
because I think especially coming out of
the MCU and like Infinity war and
Avengers in-game non-comic book readers
kind of look at Thanos as like this
super powerful all-encompassing guy not
really I could name five people right
now who were just like basically humans
with incredible power that could take
out Thanos like that they could make
Thanos with The Infinity Gauntlet look
like a kid with a pop gun so he's not as
powerful as you think he is but he still
is a very formidable person but as
powerful as Thanos is Doctor Doom would
rival him I would argue quite easily
given doctor Doom's tenacity but
especially his intelligence that would
be one amazing fight to see but the
funny thing about this is that this is
why Thanos says like I have no quarrel
with you Doctor Doom that's why Dr Doom
responds and saying that's lucky for you
Titan and the thing about this is that
when Thanos asks have you come here to
destroy the stone the response of Doctor
Doom is no it would be the least
interest way to use this power after all
if you have all of Creation in your
hands if you can change the very essence
of life and all you can think of is to
end it it speaks to a deficient
imagination now one of the things you
guys are going to notice here about
Thanos in relation to what he's doing is
that it's a little uncommon right and
it's a little strange because it kind of
flies in the face of all the different
motivations that Thanos has depicted
over the years so this might be a little
divisive I'm kind of curious to see how
you guys feel about it right the
response of Thanos here is life is
willful chaos it is destructive and
violent I have seen thousands of
civilizations and creatures none are
peaceful every single one is destructive
in some way or another the idea of
Thanos basically seizing this Stone
wiping out everything in existence and
then destroying the stone it is very
reminiscent of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe version of Thanos right that
like he has his own rhyme and reason the
comic book version of Thanos is just the
design higher to attain the bed of
mistress death literally he's trying to
get with this chick all the time right
like he's down bad for mistress death
and normally Thanos would just present
some argument of how life is meaningless
right like some nihilistic response but
approaching this more from like people
and everything is just inherently bad it
makes him sound emo but regardless of
how you slice it during this
conversation and as Dr Doom looks at the
black infinity stone which has now taken
the form of a little girl he starts to
kind of recognize her to a degree then
it Dawns on him who this little girl is
and then he immediately tries to stop
Thanos from destroying this girl the
thing about this is that suddenly Thor
intervenes and so what you get here is a
kind of three-way fight between Thor and
Thanos and Doctor Doom and it's pretty
dope it's not some Grand and all be-all
like Grand Puba style fight but it is a
pretty solid fight because Thanos and
Thor going toe-to-toe it is interesting
to see it happen because Thor is
incredibly strong and Incredibly durable
under any normal circumstance chance
Thor would get dominated here right I
mean like like it wouldn't even be close
like Thor would just get crushed but
lest we forget ever since the death of
Odin Thor has had the Odin Force right
so his power is Way Beyond what it
traditionally is and that's how he's
able to hold his own in this fight in
the first place he's able to literally
Pummel Thanos with his hammers Thanos
gets a few licks in here and there but
that's basically it Dr Doom on the other
hand ends up seizing the little girl and
then trying to get her away what he ends
up doing here is throwing her into the
time portal that Thor and Dr Doom both
used to get here in that moment as she's
sitting through this she actually starts
aging up right into a younger woman but
she doesn't know anything about herself
she doesn't know who she is she doesn't
know her own backstory but there are
bits of information that she has things
that she's almost kind of inherited
we're not really given a definitive
explanation as to why it just seems to
be bits of knowledge that she simply
just knows because they're just a part
of her existence right almost like a
genetic knowledge when it comes to human
beings or different animals and so with
lhasa also joining here from the future
she's able to kind of escort this young
girl and get her out of Harm's Way and
in the same process Thanos and Dr Doom
are tossed into the time portal and
they're basically sent back to wherever
it was they came from so this is how
Marvel's going to explain how Thanos is
currently running around in like the
present in Marvel Comics after being
timed his place from the Guardians of
the Galaxy story but for this little
girl herself or I guess really this
young woman herself with Thor rejoining
them Thor now understands exactly what
he has to do because initially he didn't
he didn't know how to handle like this
little girl this black infinity stone
that's manifested in physical form but
what he ends up doing here is grabbing
this girl and grabbing lhasa and then
jumping to yotenheim right the home of
the frost Giants and as they get there
Thor engages in what he refers to as
fine as guardian diplomacy where he
basically beats up Frost Giants
right because one of the things you
remember is that Frost Giants really
understand power and strength more than
anything else that's what's the most
important to them so if you show up in
in yotenheim with like a box of Girl
Scout cookies well you know what that's
that's that doesn't count because Girl
Scout cookies are like the universal
peace offering man especially those
caramel Twirls bruh those things are
next level but if you show up there you
know with some kind of like hey let's
talk guys they're gonna obliterate you
right they're just gonna destroy you on
the spot and so by engaging in this kind
of diplomacy this allows Thor to make
his way through yotenheim and then bring
this girl who he calls hella to the
person that is her father that he
basically tells her this is Loki and
he's your dad here's the important thing
about all of this in Marvel Comics we've
never really gotten a straightforward
origin for the character of hella and
how it relates to Loki all we've known
over the years is that hella is somehow
the daughter of Loki and that's it right
the thing about this is that while Loki
is much younger at this point in time
than he traditionally is it's going to
allow Thor to introduce hella and to say
well look he's just been around for a
really really long time but Loki this is
your daughter uh hella this is your
father and just go from there it's a
whole reworking of hella's origin in
Marvel Comics but that still doesn't
answer the question how is Thanos
walking around with a black infinity
stone on his Gauntlet where does it come
from with that being said guys we're
gonna bring this video to an end thank
you all for watching and I will catch
you all later
peace